what's up guys hope you are doing good
this is live with Mak I'm in
village and
this is the perfect example how busy
people are in the village you can see
they are really working very very very
hard guys I want you to ask yourself
this really the life where you want to
wake up to where you are being walk up
by the sounds of bir chickens the mowing
of cows and this strong wind from
trees so for me I would rather be wake
up to a beach and maybe
enjoy the swimming pool but this is
where God saided to B me and I enjoy
this place so I have to love it I have
to embrace it so guys today I'm working
in the farm you know you guys if you are
new here kindly do me that favor and hit
that subscrip button I'm a man on a
mission to step into every country and
its Villages and also taste every kind
of food raise to 3,000
subscribers and if you are H my
returning subscriber here thank you so
much may God bless you for supporting
live with Mak to this moment so I
really ask you
guys continue supporting and joining my
community I'm on the raise to 3,000
subscribers guys to 5 to
10 so kindly continue supporting live
with makori and may God bless you guys
so we are here at the farm so guys
I used to give you contents along the
video The Village I take you around
interact with some Villages but today I
decided I have to bring you right to the
farm so we have just started this we
working really really hard and this is
it
guys
so thank you so much and we are here at
the farm so new things are coming guys
you can see new things are coming up new
things are coming
up it's so nice and
guys look at this which means the rain
has not gone down well we need a lot of
rain so guys I will be planting a lot
of maze here and uh also uh I will be
having KS but I want me from this part
the other side because guys I have a a a
a mission I need to have a lot of chicks
that's why I need a lot of maze corns so
that I can have enough food that's one
way of uh trying to invest so guys today
I'm telling this place these are my
friends from the village here so uh they
are here uh when they finish they need
to get paid so I pay for them to to blow
this so maybe tomorrow and the other day
I need to look for money
for more seeds so I need seeds to plant
this place here yeah so this is it guys
I'm so excited because my farm is being
blowed you know guys when you don't have
the cows to blow or you don't have the
means to proud the the the farm it
really becomes very very very
challenging and so this is it
guys is so so amazing and I want to show
you guys I want to show you on how I do
this
[Music]
oh
guys today I've just woken up very very
hardly in the morning ah it's around let
me check on my watch what is the
time ah wow it is
710 I'm from work guys so I want to run
to the center to pick some of the things
so guys I'm so
excited so
excited
okay yeah and this is my beautiful home
so guys I was at the farm I need to run
and pick some of the things from the
center they were sent
there so
that yeah it rained a lot you
see and I have some guys at the farm so
I have to tie up my shoe so guys I'm
here in the morning and
uh yeah guys I'm heading to
town heading to
town and I want to go and it's
so guys I was asking if he can take me
to rongo but he said it's trying to pick
somebody so he cannot so guys um this is
my home home guys this is my home
Village so I'm waiting for another
motorbike to
[Applause]
come wow wow
W so guys uh I'm on it
[Music]
for
so
[Music]
so guys I'm in wrongo and I've just Pi
this was sent as aary from premium
premium car so yeah so I picked and I
have to leave
now let me wait for the
r have to leave
it was a first
thing stay for long so we need to
just this
[Music]
way so this is called rongo town so weo
Town
guys it's it's a big town and uh is
always busy see
wow oh you need to be careful when
crossing the
road that's
it okay going to pick someone else
[Music]
so guys
um we just arrived let me just this
[Music]
so guys I'm here I brought the amze man
I
brought the seeds so we are going to
plant
this
wow so I need to go and see what this
guys going to eat
breakfast
so let me check let me check them out
I'm so excited guys
because I'm going to plant
now yeah
yeah so
amazing and the sun's up so nice man so
nice
so
amazing wow guys
so we are back again
and these guys have finished this place
man wow oh you can see so very
soon I will be planting maze here I will
come and balloon this because
um
yeah trim this side
here wow wow wow
wow
hey
joh I think
foreign
fore he
higher higher
oh sassy sassy
sassy
guys so this is what we do when you come
the first day we we welcome you the
second day we give you a
j you work
so guys fuing wow this PR is really
moving down so quick
man so which means I need to start
planting any day from
tomorrow I already have one bag of maze
[Music]
guy is very
lazy oh my
God 20
20 you see the people who have
eaten
and how they do no don't lie you are
lying guys is the place
to oh my goodness but this work for real
MH it needs energy mhm and it needs
somebody who is
energetic it's not about to
eat it's not about to try no and I tried
oh my God but the reason is
guys I've just done it is not that
easy it is not that easy
wow man this place has a lot of
stones so you even
fear when you can punch that what do you
call
it the name of that
J yeah so when it punched guys it can
even destroy your leg because it's the
place
it's no no no no canot because you are
not a really farmer look at that boy
look at look at how boys
wow yeah you need to be strong man I
need to
eat or you want me to show you on how we
do let us see guys it was my turn now
it's m let us see is he going to make it
it's not that easy guys and
uh Sho all to be
honest it's just H
heavy but guys just uh tell us to come
tell us guys let us engaged comment
section tell us I and Maki see me and
see Maki are we look
like he's a muscle guy first second he
used to do this you see he has a lot of
sugar canes there this is what he do and
he used to do it so Mak don't lie to me
that you don't know this I believe that
you I am the village boy so you used to
do this yeah I see you have a lot of
sugar that is a two
haers that's two haes so mean that oh my
God oh my goodness see see how we are
doing these things man I can see
show
us the stones man don't worry about the
stones it can punch this one why why
what about what you are
doing you
see so guys that's what I was just
trying to tell you that is not that
[Music]
easy no matter what you are a village or
not it is not easy for sure not that
easy guys uh to be a villager guys to be
a farmer you need a lot of you have to
eat
ugali and M
also what else Mak without M what
else without without uh let us leave
alone M and
ugali what
else another type of food
do you have in this uh Village we have
everything yeah I just want to know that
it is
see we have
corn like this place here I want to
plant corn want to plant corns here a
lot of
corn
wow and to exit this place is it a
Hector place is over he
no how do we call
it
three4 34s guys they used
Bulls these are the Bulls they used to
uh farm with dig farm and they use that
thing I don't know the name of it what
the name of
that that one that you use
let us go across to M then he just sound
that we have not
he y you see just one hand very
energetic not a lot
of a lot of M and and sweet potatoes
here not else you know as there guys us
used to eat those soft foods rice and
all that why do you eat soft food soft
foods ugali
sometimes but here guys it's all about M
sugar can sweet potatoes
ugali yeah porridge see the Bulls are so
energetic wow look at this this
how but you're just repeating to the
same place no and you're trying to tell
us that you are that energetic very
energetic no
you are using the same same
place the place guys have uh I was just
cashing that the place that he just
continuing with and they just telling us
that he's done that energetic but guys
is re uh he's just doing amazing at this
amazing place I can't complain with it
because for sure it needs energy and uh
he's a farmer and a farmer at
need is supposed to farm I need a lot
of how can I put it
guys supposed to farm and
uh what
else yes guys guys guys kindly support
this channel by subscribing share and
comment and don't forget to like this
video guys to be recommended and guys
kindly watch this video to the end when
it pops to a screen guys don't forget
don't
watch the ads and then second guys watch
Until the End third show love guys to
this this channel support my brother
guys he has been struggling with this
for long just motiv motivate him in a
RIT where guys he's just going to enjoy
the fruits of this uh platform I just
been monetized yes but he just still
crying with fighting guys so guys I know
can make it just support him show him
some love as we are one family you know
this platform made us to be family made
us to be
one
Community made us even to know each
other there's some people from Europe
some people from Caribbean some people
even from Africa some people all over
the world this is the platform that made
us to know each other to have friends
friends to have international friends so
kindly guys
support uh in your true heart don't
support halfly just support in a full
way whereby guys actually this will just
come and I know God we just going to add
more to your pockets whereby you're
going to support these kind of people
and this is Sassy bore sassy from this
side and Sass is sasi go and check me
out and uh I will just going to
appreciate your love and support and
subscription guys is highly appreciated
so love you as we proceed to this uh
amazing and
amazing uh work over here uh this is
Africa
guys and we are Africans and Africans
must struggle African masaa I don't know
why it is like that we have use energy
we don't have the machines like other
people there we use machines to work
with it I don't know if even uh today
you uh I don't
know but
uh let me say that
actually uh we are doing and we are
using energy uh we supposed to work with
energy is not about the
machines that you put something to
machine and then it will you know I as
here it's about energy so you have to
eat
well then you're are going to you know
and you have to have that energy like
life with Maki there Y without having
that uh trust me to do that it's not
that easy
I've
tried guys you saw i' just
trying I've tried my
best uh he not that easy but kindly guys
my humble request this from my heart is
that I love you so much my colleagues my
family our community so this request
guys kindly kindly support
us uh check us out watch our videos in
the end guys we're just chasing all I'm
just hours and subscribers to go to
1,000 subscribers my brother here just
want to achieve the goals he just
monetized but he needs that uh you know
what I mean guys when I say that so
kindly
kindly don't skip this word this is the
word from my and it is from my heart
kindly I know you love him guys
you being with him
so show him some loves show him love
guys remember love is for free uh let us
not use that hum love because let us use
the God's love the way Gods love us God
show love for
us you
know let us show love like God so love
you know
so we are proceeding to this amazing
they're using the
Bulls
to is not the tractor you know guys the
tract is so
expensive so we are supposed to luse the
Bulls so
that things will just
going well
a you going to Dan this
place you will uh finish
yeah yeah you finish this
place and then you will start
planting and remember these cows use
even the
Bloods they're not
machines so be careful when you are just
dig the
stones there some stones are just not uh
what the stones will just move away
because they know who I am they know
you then they know who you
are why don't you correct these all
Stones then you sell correct I sell yeah
ah you cannot sell all these how will
you how will the veh access
this come to you
there are many stones for real many many
many
stones hold
on he was making stories nothing like
stories then you have done the story
nothing like
stories here we are not making stories
we are making history I just was making
history
also this is what we do
brother
[Applause]
oh
my even the place so
hard yeah you know the so is sock yeah
this is
R is that cray or R this is cray so
[Music]
guys I'm finishing this you're going to
done it you
helped back another
time so when you back that will be the
end bring them in this wow
so guys we have done the place and it
was Heavy let's life with Mak tell us
how do you feel man guys you must you
must eat ugali if you
eat that's sing a lot so if you eat rice
you not get this energy we believe we
will eat
ugali yeah we supposed to have
muscles muscles John Cena no no no
why
[Music]
why guys just oh my goodness do you
think this but you you just catched it
it is too heavy maybe once it's too
heavy for real but I finished already
yeah you have finished so guys we are
expecting planting tomorrow yeah is they
starting planting tomorrow the corns no
I will not start tomorrow because for
sure I need some you have need many
power many Powers many power power so
that they can help me have some hes and
then how many bags do you need this
place I need like three bags or three
bags of s of corns BS so that it can
finish this place yeah and I already
have one I went I went to Rango to bring
for my mother and uh you was I managed
to buy one m so I have one I need also
two add two I need some like like four
people mhm come and help me plant this
yeah so guys I wonder why H people they
used that common language each and every
one why you all of you just using that
common language yeah because it is our
language you know let me tell you I want
to be very very honest we were colonized
by British people mhm and they taught us
English mhm but the really sense when
people learn by their own language like
I could have they understand better
because they learn by their own language
and that's why you see the Chinese and
many people they learn by their own
language so they lied to us they they
brought us
this name this English so English is not
it's just like any other language it's
not a mes of Education or what that's
why anybody can speak in English so we
speak in our own language do you mean
that the Chinese are not speaking
English yeah most of them they don't
they learn by their their their language
but they don't speak English they speak
I I am not saying they don't speak
English just get the point straight they
speak English but it is not their main
they learn by Chinese that's why you see
this my my phone my my camera is met
from China China that's why it has you
see so that's what I'm trying to say so
we speak a lot of our vernacular
language because that's what we know in
the village here and we love speaking to
our not abandon our our ancest our
ancestoral
language no so that is it and
guys we are finished now plowing now
what I need is planting so I will need
like four men to come and help me so
that can we can plant it in one day this
place in one day and I need like uh two
more bags of maze but uh I'm going to do
it man I'm going to do it yeah I will
try my best but not tomorrow but I when
if it takes like two days yeah when if
it takes like two
days oh my goodness we we will have done
everything so guys so this is it so this
is the village our village is called
Naro Naro Village
Village yeah so guys I'm trying to car I
brought some breakfast with this so I'm
trying to carry to carry home yeah these
are it these are the utensils I need to
carry
them so we are done from the farm so
guys I want to say thank you so much
because uh even I'm going to end this
video from here I want to say thank you
so much may God bless you for watching
this video to this end
and if you like the video
kindly give it a like so that it can get
to be sent to many people so I want to
say thank you so much for the love and
support
and yeah this still live in the
village so stay tuned and see you in the
video Yeah peace man peace peace peace
peace out